The Bible reading this morning is taken from John's Gospel, chapter 14 verses 1 to 7.
Let not your hearts be troubled. Believe in God. Believe also in me.
In my Father's house are many rooms.
If it were not so, would I have told you that I go to prepare a place for you?
And if I go and prepare a place for you, I will come again and will take you to myself,
that where I am, you may be also. And you know the way to where I am going.
Thomas said to him, Lord, we do not know where you are going. How can we know the way?
Jesus said to him, I am the way and the truth and the life. No one comes to the Father except through me.
If you had known me, you would have known my Father also. From now on, you do know him and have seen him.
This is the word of the Lord.
Amen, let's pray together.
Lord, as we read a moment ago in Psalm 25, we prayed the same again.
We prayed, Lord, make known your ways to us. Teach us your paths.
Lead us in your truth and teach us for you are the God of our salvation.
And so we're looking at John chapter 14 this morning. This is the sixth of the I am statements that we're working through.
There are seven total in the gospel of John. We have the seventh in John 14, six.
When I was little, one of my favorite places to go was Nanny and Popol's house.
They lived just down the road from where we're sat here.
And I always remember just getting there. The door was never locked and so we just let ourselves in.
And every time I would go in, the first place I would go to would be the Popol's lazy boy.
And he would be sat there. He would almost never get up.
But he was always there and he was ready for a hug. We would kind of dive on him and give him a hug.
It was always wonderful to be greeted by him and to feel at home there.
But always there beside his lazy boy was a little wooden table.
And he always had a cup of coffee or a cup that had had coffee in it, the remote control and his Bible.
But there was one day when he got up from his lazy boy for the last time.
And nobody knew that that would be the case and he didn't know it either.
And when people went back to the house, I wasn't there, but they went back and they found that sure enough his Bible was there beside his chair.
And it was opened up to John chapter 14.
And what a wonderful passage of Scripture to read on your final day on earth, John chapter 14.
It's a comfort to me to think that these were the very words that he was reading on that day.
Because what Jesus says here gives us hope both in life, but also in death.
It gives us comfort for ourselves knowing where we are going, if our trust is in Jesus.
But also comfort for those that we love who know him as well.
Here Jesus shows us the way to our eternal home.
He does so by saying several different things here.
We're just going to kind of lock into three aspects.
We're going to see the problem that he and the disciples are facing.
And then we're going to see the place that he is going.
And then last of all, we're going to see the path to get there.
But let's just see the problem of what is going on here just to set the scene.
This is a very difficult time for Jesus and for his disciples.
Last week, we were looking at the very public raising of Lazarus.
And we mentioned that right after that, we see that that is the very thing that sets the plan to put Jesus to death in motion.
Alright, so this is a very public thing.
People are already looking to put him to death.
But now that many people have seen this and they believe they want to put Jesus to death.
The religious authorities do anyway.
So you've got this possibility of death looming over their heads.
And the disciples are really feeling this.
And so you have this kind of external problem, if you will, that's looming.
So they know that the hour of death has come for Jesus, that that is near.
They know that they are in danger as well.
And so Jesus knows that this is coming to him.
But here what we see is it's not so much a problem as it is God's purpose being fulfilled.
This is the very purpose for which Jesus came to die on the cross.
And so you read in John chapter 12 verses 27 and 28, Jesus prays, he says this.
He says, now is my soul troubled.
And what shall I say?
Father, save me from this hour.
But for this purpose I have come to this hour.
Father, glorify your name.
So Jesus knows that he's come for this purpose, for this very hour.
The hour of his death.
And the glory that God will receive through it.
So Jesus then gathers his disciples after praying this.
And he speaks to them in private in what has come to be known as the farewell discourse.
If you have a Bible open in front of you and you've got words in red, you'll see words in red over the next few chapters.
As Jesus is gathering his disciples to speak to them for this final time.
It's night time.
They know that Jesus' life is under threat and Jesus then tells them near the start.
He tells them that one of them is going to betray or, yeah, one of them is going to betray Jesus.
Of course we then know that that is Judas.
And then after he says that one of them is going to betray him, then you've then got Peter talking about how he's never going to deny Jesus.
And Jesus says this very night, you are going to deny me.
So these are really troubling times here.
But it's not just about the external trouble that is happening.
It's also about the internal kind of trouble that is going on in the disciples, the turmoil they are facing.
As they're hearing that somebody is about to betray Jesus.
Peter says he's willing to lay down his life for Jesus, but Jesus says you're going to deny him.
So they feel the kind of darkness surrounding them.
And yet Jesus says in verse one of chapter 14,
Let not your hearts be troubled.
Where troubled conveys the idea of a kind of strong inner turmoil.
That's what they're feeling in the midst of these difficult circumstances.
But you can imagine them hearing Jesus say this after all he's just said about betrayal and denial to then say let not your hearts be troubled.
I mean, not to trivialize this at all, but I can't help but think about, you know, buzz saying to Woody,
Now, Woody, this is no time to panic. And Woody answers, this is a perfect time to panic.
You know, so Jesus is saying don't be troubled.
The disciples are like, what do you mean, don't be troubled?
How could Jesus possibly say this facing death?
You know, these disciples have left behind everything to follow Jesus.
Now it seems like all of that is going to be for nothing.
And they may very well lose their lives because of this too.
How could Jesus say don't be troubled?
This is not a kind of grandiose statement that dismisses their concerns or is detached from reality or the reality of the difficulties they are facing.
Because the very word he uses to speak to his disciples here when he says, let not your hearts be troubled was what he said in his prayer a moment ago.
That's why I read it in chapter 12 verse 27.
He says, Father, my soul is troubled.
So he's experiencing this trouble.
And the inner turmoil wasn't like forever gone once he had prayed.
It returns again.
So when Jesus begins this kind of final discourse in chapter 13 verse 21, we're told that he was troubled in spirit.
So what we have here is this troubled man Jesus saying to his troubled disciples, let not your hearts be troubled.
So here we see that Jesus knows exactly how they are feeling and more when he says this to them.
And yet in his time of greatest need, his thought is for his disciples.
He is taking care of them.
And the same is true of us.
When he says to us, don't let your hearts be troubled.
This is somebody who knows exactly what it is to suffer like we suffer and even more.
And this is him speaking to us from a place of genuine care, knowing what we need.
He knows what it's like to experience turmoil, trouble.
And yet he says, don't be troubled.
He gives the flip side of being troubled.
He says, believe in God.
Believe also in me.
He isn't saying believe God exists and your troubles will go away.
He's telling the disciples that in the midst of their fear, they can still put their faith in God and hold on to him and what he has promised.
In the midst of their fear, he calls them to faith.
So they know that they're to believe God.
But notice what he says after that, believe in God, believe also in me.
So what is Jesus telling us about himself there?
He's saying that he is as trustworthy as the Father.
They can trust in his word as the very word of God.
Why?
Because he is, as we've been seeing, the I am.
So in the midst of trouble and uncertainty, he is the constant.
He is the certainty.
The hope in the midst of turmoil is found by trusting in him.
So when we are faced with uncertainty, even the uncertainty of death, we can place our hope in the certainty of his promises.
Now they may or may not disappear immediately the troubles that we're facing.
But Jesus is pointing us to where our hope is found and it is found in him.
Alright, so Jesus then takes this general statement about their trouble and trusting in God, this problem that they're facing.
But then he applies it specifically to death.
Because that is what they are facing specifically here.
What he says gives us hope in the face of death.
He talks about the place where he's going.
This is where, this is the truth he wants them to believe about the place he's going.
He says, believe also in me, verse 2,
In my father's house are many rooms.
If it were not so, what I've told you that I go to prepare a place for you.
So Jesus tells them he's going to his father's house.
He's going to prepare a place for them.
If you grew up in church, you'll probably heard and sung songs based on this very verse.
I grew up in, once a couple different churches, but one was pretty traditional.
And so we would open up our hymn books and we would sing, I've got a mansion just over the hilltop.
Does anybody know that song?
And we would sing about the mansion that was based on a translation, the King James version of this.
Where it says in my father's house are many mansions, but that word doesn't mean kind of how we think of it now.
So it was confusing and we all thought we were going to get a mansion one day.
It's going to be great, but it may not be exactly as we thought in that song.
But then things got cleared up when I went to a youth group and we sang the classic Theologically Sounds.
Big house by Audio Adrenaline.
Common Go With Me to My Father's House.
Do you remember how it was described?
It's a big, big house with lots and lots of room.
It's a big, big table with lots and lots of food.
A big, big yard where we can play football.
It's a big house.
It's my father's house.
This is the word of the Lord.
If you gather around my bedside and I'm dying, it'd be wonderful to have a song or two, but please don't sing that song.
So there's a lot of ideas floating around, speculation about what heaven is like.
But it is important to see what scripture teaches and stick with that.
And what it emphasizes as well.
So where is Jesus going?
He's going to the Father's house.
So the focal point though of what Jesus is saying here is not what the house is like, but whose house it is.
He's going to the house of the Father.
And he's using the imagery of a house to speak of God's dwelling place.
So he's speaking of dwelling in God's presence and finding our home in Him.
This is where Jesus is heading to the presence of his Father.
And God's house or his dwelling is a theme that stretches right the way throughout scripture.
So Adam and Eve are dwelling with God in the cool of the garden.
You've got 2 Samuel 7 and verse 13 where God says that David's offspring is going to build a house for my name.
See this being fulfilled initially in the temple that is built where God's presence is made known among his people.
But that was ultimately pointing to the coming of Jesus and him building his church.
So in 2 Corinthians chapter 6 verse 16 we the church are referred to as the temple of the living God, the Lord's house.
He makes his dwelling in us as his people.
And then in John chapter 14 and verse 23 Jesus speaks in that way about God making his home with us.
So chapter 14 verse 23 if you've got a Bible with you have a look at that verse.
Jesus speaks about the Father, he and the Father making their home with us.
They're taking up residence in the lives of those who love him.
How does this happen?
It happens when the Holy Spirit comes and takes up residence in us.
So there's a very real sense in which we the church are the Father's house where he makes up his home with us.
But at the same time at the start of the chapter that's not what it's saying.
So yes God takes up residence in us but in the start of the chapter this is not a place for God to dwell.
It's a place for us to dwell in the Father's house.
So this is the people of God being welcomed into the presence of God.
It is us going to our heavenly home where there are many rooms.
There's room for everyone who puts their faith in Christ all over the world.
If you dwell or rather if he dwells in you you will dwell with him.
This is what is being taught here.
So we're dwelling in the presence of God.
So when will that happen?
When will we dwell in the presence of God?
When will we go to the Father's house to be with him?
Forever.
Is it when we die?
Or is it when Jesus comes again?
What does Scripture teach?
We touched on this in passing last week but I thought it would be good for us to slow down a little bit this week and see what Scripture says about this.
So what happens when a believer dies?
Well two things.
One is there's what theologians tend to refer to as the intermediate state.
The intermediate state.
What do I mean by that?
I don't mean purgatory.
That's not what Scripture teaches.
What Scripture teaches is that when we die physically, spiritually we go to be with the Lord.
And it's that state of spiritually being with the Lord that is that kind of intermediate state being with the Lord spiritually.
So what are some examples of this in Scripture?
So Luke 23 verse 43.
You've got the thief next to Jesus on the cross.
Jesus says, truly truly I say to you today you will be with me in paradise.
So that very day when he dies, the thief was going to be with him in paradise.
Though his body died, his spirit will be with the Lord.
Second Corinthians chapter 5 verses 6 to 8.
There we see that the language of home is being used to describe leaving our physical bodies and going to be with the Lord.
So second Corinthians 5 says while we are at home in the body, we are away from the Lord.
But we would rather be away from the body and at home with the Lord.
Philippians chapter 1 verse 23.
Paul talks about how his life was under threat.
He could die but he was comforted because he knew that if he were to die he would be with Christ, he says.
And then he says that is far better to be with Christ.
Okay, so what does Scripture teach then about what's going to happen when believers die?
Well, spiritually we will go to be with the Lord.
And being with him is far better than life even as we know it now at the best of times.
And yet there is even more to come after that.
Because Scripture doesn't just teach us about that kind of intermediate state when we are with the Lord.
Spiritually, it also speaks about something that's going to happen physically after that.
It speaks of the resurrection of the body.
That's the other thing that Scripture teaches as well.
So this is why NT Wright says heaven is important but it's not the end of the world.
So there's more to come. Heaven's wonderful, not the end of the world.
So the resurrection of the body is the eternal hope that we have to look forward to.
So our eternal hope is not escaping this physical world so that we can kind of live in a disembodied world.
We can live in a state forever.
Wonderfully our souls go to be with the Lord when we die but our eternal hope isn't escape.
It is resurrection.
It's resurrection.
So just as Jesus physically rose again from the dead, there's coming a day when he will raise all who belong to him physically to be with him forever.
So where do we see this in Scripture?
We'll hold your place and turn it to me to John chapter 5.
John chapter 5 verse 28 to 29.
Jesus says, do not marvel at this.
For an hour is coming when all who are in the tombs will hear his voice.
Just like we saw with Lazarus last week.
What will happen when they hear his voice?
They will come out.
Those who have done good to the resurrection of life and those who have done evil to the resurrection of judgment.
Here you have good works demonstrating that we belong to the world.
They're not the means by which we're saved or saved by grace through faith that is seen and how we live.
But those who belong to the Lord will come out of their graves to the resurrection of life when the Lord speaks.
So if we are already with the Lord spiritually, well when Jesus speaks and we come out of our tombs,
well what is actually coming out of the tomb?
Our physical selves.
So when will that happen?
When Jesus' voice, when he speaks, well when is that?
It's what Jesus tells us in John chapter 14, the passage we're looking at this morning.
So John chapter 14 and verse 3, Jesus tells us when he's going to bring us to the Father's house.
He says, and if I go and prepare a place for you, I will come again and will take you to myself.
That where I am, there you may be also.
So here's what scripture teaches.
It teaches that when Jesus returns, we will be raised from the dead.
To be with him.
So you can look at another passage of scripture.
I'll just go ahead and read it. You can turn there for your life.
First Thessalonians chapter 4 verses 14 to 17 says this,
For since we believe that Jesus died and rose again, even so through Jesus,
God will bring with him those who have fallen asleep.
That's our physical death there.
For this we declare to you by a word from the Lord that we who are alive,
who are left until the coming of the Lord will not proceed those who have fallen asleep.
For the Lord himself will descend from heaven with a cry of command,
with the voice of an archangel, with the sound of the trumpet of God.
And the dead in Christ will rise first.
Then we who are alive, who are left, will be caught up together with them in the clouds to meet the Lord in the air.
And so we will always be with the Lord.
What then of the physical world then?
So where will we be with the Lord?
We're in the Father's house, but where is that? Where are we going to be forever?
Romans chapter 8 verse 21 says,
The creation itself will be set free from its bondage to corruption
and obtain the freedom of the glory of the children of God.
Matthew chapter 5 and verse 5, Jesus says that God's children will inherit the earth.
Okay, so what's happening then?
So Jesus returns when he does, the dead in Christ rise.
And after that creation itself is redeemed and God brings about a new creation.
And there we will be at home with God forever.
This is the Father's house.
This is our eternal hope, being with God forever.
New heavens and the new earth.
So much more we could look at.
I'm sure that raises a lot of questions.
I'd be happy to chat with you if you would like.
Let's not miss the point of it all.
What's the point of it?
We will be at home with God.
He is the point.
He is the one who makes heaven heaven.
So greater than everything we have to look forward to in eternity is the one we will be with there.
As Psalm 43 says, he is our exceeding joy.
As Psalm 16 says, it is in his presence that there is fullness of joy.
As Psalm 90 and verse 1 says, he is our dwelling place throughout all generations.
He is God himself who will satisfy our longings for home, for permanence, for welcome.
He is our hope. He is our home.
If you've seen the movie 13 Hours, the kind of war movie, it's a really powerful movie.
But at the end of it, so you've got these different soldiers in Libya who are having to protect some folks to summarize it very briefly.
And then at the end of the movie, after several of them have died, they're then talking to one another.
They're talking about the people they've had to protect and they were kind of saying, you know, these people we've had to protect,
they're going to be getting all these kind of awards and accolades.
And then one of them says, they said, well, what are we going to get?
And one soldier looks to another, he says, we get to go home.
He was looking forward, not to his house. He was looking forward to being with his family.
So this is the hope here. Yes, we're experiencing all this trouble in the world.
What do we have to look forward to? Home with the Lord.
This is our hope. But how's that going to happen?
Well, Jesus says, I am going to prepare a place for you.
He repeats himself, if I go to prepare a place for you, verse three.
I used to think when Jesus said he's going to prepare a place for us,
you can imagine with thinking about all those mansions and glory that Jesus for the past 2,000 years has been on this like heavenly construction project,
building these mansions and all these rooms and whatever.
And you think we've had a lot of time to prepare all of these rooms or these mansions or whatever.
But remember when Jesus says, I'm going to prepare a place for you in the presence of the Father, where is Jesus about to go?
He's about to go to the cross.
He's about to go to the tomb where he is then going to be raised from the dead and he's going to then go to be with his father.
So how does Jesus prepare a place for us by dying in our place and rising again?
So how can sinful people dwell in the presence of a holy God forever?
How can imperfect people be in heaven and yet heaven still be perfect?
The answer is because Jesus died for our sins and he rose again.
He's the one who prepares this place for us in the presence of God by doing all that is necessary for us to be able to have a place there.
Okay, so that's the place being with God, being satisfied in him forever in his presence.
Also we see lastly the path that leads us there.
Over time Julia and I have gotten better at using a shared Google calendar.
But it's still taking time.
But there's been many times where she's told me something, you know, we've got this meeting coming up, we've got to be there.
And I've acknowledged and I knew what she said at the time.
But for the life of me, I can't remember it after she said it.
She may have repeated it again and I have to hear it again.
So finally we get to this place where it actually needs to be written down or my computer is reminding me.
Otherwise it's like she never said it in the first place.
Well here Jesus has just told his disciples, this is where I'm going.
This is how you're going to get there.
And so Thomas says to Jesus, what does he say?
Lord we don't know where you're going and how can we know the way?
Jesus patiently with Thomas as he is with us says essentially everything that he's just said but he draws it all together in this succinct, simple yet utterly powerful statement.
One of the first scriptures many of us memorized, John 14.6.
Thomas, I am the way, the truth and the life.
No one comes to the Father except through me.
You want to know the way to the Father?
Let me break it down for you.
I am the way.
It is Jesus.
He's the one who takes us there.
We can trust in him.
When we lived in West Africa we met all sorts of really interesting people.
But one time we spoke with this missionary lady who had been living in another West African country.
And she, in that country there was a coup d'etat.
You know the government had been overthrown and so she was having to flee the country and she got connected with some high up military official from a neighboring country.
And ended up being loaded up into the back of his truck and he was in the back of the truck there with her.
And so they're speeding towards the border of the southern country.
And as they're kind of going down this road in this really dangerous situation she then realizes that she's forgotten her laissez-passe.
And your laissez-passe was essentially, it was like a permit, almost like a visa that got you into all these different West African countries.
She's flying down the road towards the border of the southern country with war breaking out around her and she's forgotten her permit, her laissez-passe.
She's like, oh no, what am I going to do? We can't turn around water.
And so she speaks up to this high up military official and she says, I'm so sorry, I've forgotten my laissez-passe.
And he looked down at her and he said, I am your laissez-passe.
In other words, he was getting into the country and he was her means by which she was getting into the country.
I am all you need to get through.
This is essentially what Jesus is saying here.
He's saying this is what you need to know.
I am the one who will bring you there.
I am the way, the truth and the life.
It isn't that we kind of try to find our way to God or we hold ourself all the way to glory.
No, Jesus is the way.
He's the one who brings us there.
He says I will bring you to my self where I am there.
He is the way.
And he gives some supporting statements to telling us that he's the way.
So what he says, I am the way, the truth and the life.
Most would say, and I think this is right, that when he's talking about the truth and the life,
that's really supporting what he's saying about being the way.
So I am the way because I am the truth.
I am the perfect revelation of God himself.
So Jesus is the word made flesh.
It is through him as we see in verse seven here, that we come to know the Father.
So he's the truth who reveals God.
So if you're looking for the way that leads to God, look to Jesus because he's the revelation of God.
He's the truth.
But also he is the life.
The disciples are so troubled at the thought of death.
This trouble remains with us to this very day.
It's scary to think about our death or the death of those we love.
As the poet Dylan Thomas put it, we do not go gentle into that good night.
We rage, rage against the dying of the light.
So we know that death isn't right and it troubles us and we rage against it.
That will not lead us to life, however much we rage against it.
Eternal life is found in the one who is the source of life.
Jesus is the life.
Therefore he can say, I am the way because I'm the source of life eternal.
We have to also bring up that this is an exclusive statement.
No one comes to the Father, no one.
Except through me.
So Jesus is not one way to choose amongst many.
He is the only way that leads to the Father.
I realize that's an offensive statement to many but it is what Jesus taught and it is the truth.
He is the way exclusively.
So 2 Timothy chapter 2 and verse 5 says that this way there is one God
and there is one mediator between God and man.
The man Christ Jesus.
Only he can be the way.
His message is truly unique.
Every other religion, even the secular kinds, focus on what you can do to get to whatever it is you're hoping in.
So the secular version might be like this is all there is.
So you're living your best life now.
This is the trend you need to get on board with.
This is the path to a healthy, fulfilling life.
There are some good things, good advice out there.
We can devote ourselves to some earthly hope and just really focus on that as the way as though that was what life was all about.
There are religious versions of it.
It might be the Islamic view of paradise and the five pillars to get us to paradise.
You can think of just any other faith in the world or even the southern, he's a good Christian, she's a good Christian.
You know, kind of statement of just thinking like, oh, there's these church things that we do.
We tithe and we, you know, we're good neighbors and we read our Bibles and we pray and that gets us to the Father.
What Jesus says is totally different.
He himself is the way we're saved through faith in him.
He says, believe in God, believe also in me through his death and resurrection.
He has prepared this place to the Father's house.
So in this world of trouble that our trust in him set our hope on the promise of his coming and live in light of that.
May that be a comfort to us in life and in death.
May it be a comfort to us when we see those we love facing the same thing.
The Heidelberg Catechism will end with this.
Asks a wonderful question.
It's asked this question, what is your only comfort in life and death?
Here's the answer that I am not my own, but belong body and soul in life and in death to my faithful savior, Jesus Christ.
Amen.